the village of bulgar is high up in the
mountains overlooking the shyok river in
Pakistan these are rich grazing grounds
but they only exist thanks to the
efforts of a group of men who've tapped
water from an uncommon Source a glacier
cell phone videos from nearly 20 years
ago show how they traveled up mountains
to more than 5,000 m above sea level to
create a stable Source They Carried
water into the mountains so it could
freeze and begin the process of Glacier
formation something they call Glacier
grafting villagers in gilat baltistan
use Ancient techniques reinforced by
modern methods to create small glaciers
in order to ensure water for their crops
and they're
successful we grafted this glass here in
2005 for this purpose we brought black
and white two types of ice from chn
colle Ed water from the river Shu and
grafted it on a 12,500 ft high mountain
it grew with the time and providing us
with the sufficient water previously we
didn't have any crops here but now we
are growing wheat potato and aprico here
countries in the Himalayas have also
invested in Glacier grafting with
encouraging results and the technique is
being refined the science I think is
more important which says that you have
to first all find or select a site which
is on the rear side of the Sun that
would mean that there is low melting
point number one number two where the
precipitation is relatively high and you
can expect more uh precipitation to
happen so that the glacier mass is
accumulated uh over the years he says
such experiments have been carried out
in the Himalayas Hindu Coos and PIR
mountains and now scientists and local
communities are exploring traditional
and these new methods to mitigate the
effects of global warming Kamal Haider
Al jazer G in gilg
bstan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer